so here we go it is 69 wool and it does
have wool it's all loud 20
six percent hurry
[__] hurry dude
drunk
[Music]
dude when you weren't here for the few
times you weren't here I missed having
all those drinks on the table yeah what
did you do you cried nope didn't even
think about it oh you just said Mist I
know what is you didn't so you didn't
let's talk about what missing something
is or someone oh oh I don't think we
have to because everybody knows what it
is I know but but what is it to you is
it a Feeling
or is it a thought what is it because I
have I've often one feeling it's a
feeling yeah you miss someone you miss
other company so you don't miss like or
or I guess you could say I miss like
some restaurant that shuttered recently
like yes the food so it's a feeling yeah
of nostalgia that you wish you had that
again
uh not necessarily Nostalgia but it
could be for sure it could also just be
like you know forlorn you miss someone
you love it's not just you long for the
past but you want that person with you
now yeah you're right so you miss
sometimes you're you're your loved ones
do you miss friends
do I miss friends no I don't there you
go you're a hard you're a hard dude I
have always had a strange relationship
not to my friends but to the idea of
friends people seem to rely on friends
more than I do that's true of you though
too right
uh that I don't rely on my friends yeah
well I don't mean like they're
unreliable but you don't
typically
I don't know actually lean on your
friends do you no more now yeah most
people do it's probably a healthy thing
it is a healthy thing yeah and I'm
unhealthy do you ever miss me
uh yeah I guess so actually be more
convinced about like I miss my family
sometimes yeah but that might just be
Nostalgia I probably don't need you well
we also you do but also we we also see
each other so much yeah how long would
it take for you to miss me
well now we see each other every single
week basically no matter what and
because of this but how long would it
take for you to miss me
five or six years no like uh five or six
weeks probably really like over a month
would be like damn I haven't seen you in
forever yeah oh
okay do you ever only ask because you
wanted to feel good when I have friends
that they're like man I missed you man
you believe them when they say that to
you I believe them but it always makes
me feel like [__] oh really because you
go like I don't really miss you yeah I
mean there's some no there are some
friends that I do miss like friends that
have moved away that I'm like damn that
guy was so fun to be around her whatever
okay yeah I just like what is it the
feeling sometimes sometimes I feel like
a robot like Dave Miller
yeah like when I saw him at uh yeah it
was nice it was nice yeah yeah it was
nice sometimes you don't really you
realize exactly you miss someone until
they You Know You Don't Know What You
Got Till It's Gone right right well no
that's not really what I wanted
[Music]
let's go castrato
you know what a castrato is yeah the
church in my choirs used to cut careful
not careful I didn't say anything I cut
the nuts off of The Sopranos to keep
them with the high voice and snip snip
so they could still sing with a high
voice oh I got a better idea get girls
yeah I gotta get better I get I got a
better idea keep getting new ones keep
getting new people yeah because people
you don't even need to keep they just
keep coming at you they really don't do
that huh yeah man your voice is so great
dude can I uh snip your walnuts please
yeah but honestly they don't need to do
that because I'm 43. my walnuts
descended and I can be oh
it's so [__] strained no what
happened was I said yeah what what does
it have to do I just hate what does it
happen but doesn't mean anything when
you eat the mucus gets active disgusting
okay I didn't want you to say anything
about mucus
[Music]
wow wow that was so bad did it so quiet
because you couldn't do it any louder
because it hurts
that's not true
castrato anyways you said no it's
castrati no it's not that's Illuminati
dude sandwiches no castrati is not
something maybe it's maybe it's like
several yeah a bunch of castrato or
Cristiano balls orchestratis no it's not
just kids on the buses because I'm about
to sing for the church right well in
their choir well okay
here we go a castrata isn't that crazy
that it really was a thing is a type of
classical male singing voice equivalent
to the person of a soprano soprano or
Contra the voice is produced by oh
castration of the singer before great oh
great it also doesn't that doesn't work
dude
also the first guy to try it what if hey
what the it didn't work yeah seriously
what like a barbaric let me get my balls
people were
awful to each other like people like to
say like oh my God things are so bad now
and they are but like think about how
what it was just even just a hundred
years ago forget about this this is like
people were so terrible to each other
just priests being like let me cut off
your balls just oh you're good let me
cut off your boss people are always bad
you know
yeah it's all relative for sure I'm just
saying it's never gonna get better yeah
of course not people love conflict and
they love to make other people feel
dominated by them it's a deeper no I'm
saying that's why things will never
really actually change oh it's deeper
no look deep in my eyes when you said it
you know what I'm pissed about what
7-Eleven doesn't offer normal Coca-Cola
anymore it only offers these big giant
teeth rotting coca-colas well and
stomach stomach lining rotting as well
dude that's disgusting man but you how
often do you drink Cokes
I honestly only like to drink them while
I'm eating I opened this while we were
eating discarding the question now it's
gonna be like well no it's part of my
answer I drink like half or less of a
Coke ever almost every time I eat in the
day during the day so like when I have
Cokes a day no like no during the day
then lunch uh it's like a Coke so like a
half a Coke yeah well you have dinner
and also lunch so but I don't usually
drink Coke at dinner
not always then
so not always then when you eat like you
just said right only when I eat we are
and you eat lunch and dinner but you
don't do it at dinner you said you do it
at lunch so we're getting the
nitty-gritty of it yeah I guess if
there's something about this that is the
nitty-gritty you could say this is it so
what I'm saying is I am good at getting
the nitty grittiest stuff
[Applause]
dude if I'm gonna go highlight that you
don't I know you were gonna go out like
that well I did it first okay go I was
will be at wow Philadelphia Pennsylvania
uh places in Pennsylvania I will be in
uh Ohio I will be oh wait no Ohio was uh
so I will be in Boise uh Salt Lake City
give them scrolling keep him scrolling
Tucson Arizona Pueblo Colorado Colorado
Springs Charlotte North Carolina
Knoxville Little Rock Memphis for some
reason uh Nashville Calgary Edmonton
Ottawa Montreal Hamilton Pittsburgh
Cleveland Detroit yeah all the different
ones yay
chrisley.com go get it dude chrisley.com
if you want one-on-one advice sessions
with Matt go to uh uh mattelier.com yes
obviously and then you get the new merch
you get that purple people with the
hoodie or the lifeline actually the
merch of the lifeline is very very cool
uh watch lifeflight.com leave us a
message the hotline two one three nine
uh73-8095 and that's what's up whenever
you say leave us do you think beave us
and then think about beavers and
Butthead of course not of course not
that's something that I would never
think of I do dude Beavis and Butthead
is the funniest I think it's the
funniest show of all time I think Beavis
has a funny show of all time it's
definitely up there for sure it's just
too simple and silly for me to just look
past it yeah yeah
funniest full stop just show whatever
yeah I think so damn I mean I have to
think about well I think so Ricky gera's
office maybe more but but that's also
good though it's not just funny it's so
funny but Beavis and Butthead is every
single moment is funny yeah even them
walking yeah you know yeah anyway okay
well hopefully Mike Judge is listening
to this uh you know what and he'll feel
very flattered hopefully abuse or
Butthead is listening to this but I will
say this I will say this
um last episode of uh Lifeline I think
the reunion was the best episode of
Lifeline
um High bar for this episode much okay
uh High bar for this episode much
that's the most insecure thing you can
possibly do okay well we'll see who's
secure by the end of this episode uh
yeah I guess so uh
uh sibling rivalry much no that makes me
cringe even though you're not why do you
get even when somebody you know when
people do cringe stuff yeah like I was
watching this show um
shoot I don't know what it is so taxing
and so clean okay yeah because we're
still early on Wow made up a reason for
it after the fact that's not true stop
doing the thing that you're doing in
your mouth I have a hangnail that's why
okay I can't leave it I I can't put your
fingers in your mouth and
[Laughter]
um
leave us
dude it's the best podcast of all time
right just look how great it is we
connected it this is but we connected
bane of my existence are your feelings
about your own tattoos okay but we
connected it though and that and that
deserves a round of applause oh wait
dude you mean like every tattoo ever
that's not true they're completed the
tattoo that's not true there's piecemeal
tattoos there's piecemeal tattoos that
end up getting finished no not always
dude sometimes people just do Patchwork
you're saying that there are people who
like that said in three appointments for
their tattoo they only get two and then
like they forget and never get it again
I'm saying I get this one this one this
one this one I didn't necessarily mean
want to connect it maybe I will maybe I
won't oh which ones did you connect
this one and that one
why because I wanted to connect it and
guess what's connecting next time
there's nothing there though but there's
gonna be one okay well what's it gonna
be I don't know maybe a picture of you
oh my god dude well that would be
gamerville dude I don't ever want to do
a portrait I don't like portrait no [__]
really you know why because
photorealistic anything sucks no yeah
dude you don't want like an actual
depiction of a person on your body why
because you're already a whole person
because you are a person you don't need
another additional person on you think
about what I always think about with
this stuff is like think about a person
with that having sex yeah I know like if
you don't want to look at Steve Jobs
while you're having sex with the guy
you're having sex with me hey you're gay
um I had I had sex with a woman once and
she had her uh grandfather tattooed on
her no on her eye on her hip and it was
Megan it was naked I had to look at her
grandfather in the eye too he was
looking at me also dude that Steve Jobs
iconic thing where he's like this do you
know the secret that's not his hand
that's also the most gamer dude he he
appropriated the gamerville thing I
think from the different culture all
right well I have a biggest hangout of
all time okay well shut up about it I
have a conspiracy theory why is Bill uh
Bill Steve Jobs always touching his face
all right so um
all right so wow so let's get into it
you know it's lifeline and let's get
into some videos I have a hangnail and
it's fine I'm gonna be in Nashville
coming up here so chrisley.com so here
we go
absolutely no through line hey Matt hey
Chris so I thought I would just give you
a little update
um I actually took the advice that you
gave to a guy that came on the Pod a
while ago his name was River and you
told him that when somebody gets your
name wrong on purpose write all of them
down on a note card and then give it to
them when they say it so they're
immediately called out yep I have the
same problem my name is Daley and people
call me monthly yearly whole thing so a
guy did it I he called me like yearly I
think and I shuffled through my wallet
and I found the note card that said
yearly and gave it to him and he got so
upset he ripped up the note card tossed
it at me and he sat there and cussed me
out for like a minute and he was like do
you have anything to say I was like I
win you lose and it's your fault you
lost
here
literally ever dude say say hey yearly
because this is what happened say hey
hey early hey yearly
laughs
yeah that's exactly what happened
and then I took it and cried for a
minute and then ripped it up and threw
it back in your face did you have
anything to say do you have anything to
say I went the weirdest interaction of
all time I mean you lose no first first
of all let's get this out of the way
that was great I'm so glad she took our
devices do too but but here's just real
quick before we get into anything else
about it okay her name is daily
obviously the best thing to call her is
Tim Daly after the great actor Tim Daly
I don't know if that's the best that's
obviously the number one best thing to
do because Tim Daly is a great actor I
know if there's a number one best thing
to do and that's and then it wouldn't
offend her either though because she'd
be like oh everybody likes Tim Daly no
she might not even know I get I
guarantee she doesn't know who Tim Daly
is Tim Daly this is a little known
secret he's the best actor of all time
well that's a very little known secret
watch watch
watch Wings yeah dude or or The Sopranos
he's amazing in The Sopranos is he I
didn't even know he was in it dude wait
have you seen this around is he play the
main guy no
yeah he's Tony Soprano no dude he's the
guy who's in Chris's AAA group that ends
up being his sponsor okay it's so good
maybe I didn't get that okay well you're
an idiot then he's the best okay
let's give it up for Tim Daly that's
awesome she took our advices for another
guy see that's for real yeah the thing
about this podcast is our advices work
for different people that's why this
podcast is so good that's why it's so
wide reaching oh oh wait dude you're
saying the most obvious thing in the
world
oh dude okay we did it we found the
single most obvious thing in the world
to say throughout the show
that's what the show is literally people
watch it and hear advice for one person
and think oh that could work for me yeah
dude but that's why it's good I didn't
know that well then you're dumb we've
been doing this over a year and that's
what the show is we're starting a
patreon soon we gotta figure out what
the patreon is well now that you know
what the show is maybe we can figure
that out yeah see that was the problem
all right look at that nice purple okay
selling it QVC
look look at this we got one left we
have a beautiful purple look at that
look at it look at it too look at it it
actually is really great look at it not
it's and it's made out of nice material
too it's gonna keep you warm it's got uh
it's made in Tunisia look at that how
many Dewey it's French how many do we
have left do we have just because I wear
this one all the time dry clean only I
you know you can get away with not doing
it
um it is so here we go it is 69 wool and
it does have wool so loud but
um it doesn't itch you like usual wool
20. six percent polyamide now that's
what I like this they really tell you
the exact amount
five percent Ultras fibers hurry
[__] hurry dude drag queen only you
can get away with not yeah I've worn
this six times already you don't even
have drop on it and I spill
getting lost in it you know just did it
did it did a whole acting performance
you get this absolute Beauty it's purple
it's Violet it's you know it's in the
it's in that family of color
right now seven payments six dollars
so that's you do that's 30 some yeah and
you know most people will spend that on
on a sandwich or two depending on where
you live right oh wow relating to us
yeah see that's I would be really good
at QVC dude if I was listening to this
podcast and that happened I would be so
mad why that it took a detour just
basically just sounded like an actual
QVC like imagine somebody listed that in
the car yeah it just like sounded like a
QVC show yeah yeah so not good though so
that's bad and people are no it's not
good dude we've got oh no you can do it
with anything there are two okay so look
all right here's what we're gonna do so
we have a period we'll mix them up which
ones which did the switcheroo on you
that's mine that's yours so I have the
you gave me the and this is just
this is this is periodas finest now it's
got the yellow label one right here it's
carbonated
mineral water
that uh you know this is captured the
source in France so you know France when
they come to water especially if you've
got bubbles in it right
one of the one of these
would sell at your average what would it
sell for what three dollars
we are going to have two
right now
1.50 so that you are getting
stop
you know what I mean
how many times
for the price of it not one less than
one and you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna throw
always throwing in a nearby thing you
know
you know what we're gonna throw in um
we have napkins
[__] now I forgot which one's mine you
[__] you you said the yellow one was
mine right okay yeah there we go
taste that don't it taste beautiful all
right um so anyway next one I guess how
many times you've done that alone you
know oh so many times yeah it's
upsetting
hey Chris Matt uh you guys rock I want
to show you guys hilarious
um so I work at a dealership and uh the
other day I was putting an inquiry on K
Blue Book for one of my customers to get
a value on their vehicle and you have to
put your information in I didn't want
people contacting me so I input a fake
name
um Mike Hunt if you say it a certain way
let me know what that sounds like but I
put in my work email on my phone number
basically and it went out to a bunch of
I didn't know at the time but when you
put that information it goes out to a
bunch of dealerships and this one guy at
another dealership he calls me uh at 7
pm on a Sunday all dealership close on
Sunday so this guy literally has no life
um and he's I'm having dinner with my
wife and he's like yelling at me cussing
me I think that's funny you think that's
really funny and like cursing me out but
um whatever I just kind of blew him off
because like this guy's crazy yes and
but apparently he knows the owner of my
dealership uh so my boss and the next
day my boss has a talk with me and kind
of chews me out a little bit but I
didn't really apologize I didn't think I
was in the wrong because this guy's just
psychopath obviously but I don't know
um she said it was really unprofessional
I don't know I I felt kind of bad but I
don't know do you think I've been wrong
here or is this guy just crazy like I
think he is I don't know let me know
what you think I appreciate the help uh
you guys are hilarious keep doing what
you're doing awesome thank you bro who
[__]
care Toyota
I mean I get that why though they don't
want [__] it's Mike Hunt he wrote
Mike Hunt there's no bad words on it
it's only for internal people's eyes
like who cares okay so it didn't say
c-u-n-t okay yeah no it's Mike Hunt
that's the joke it's like see more butts
it's just more it's a more heavily
evolved bleep it Jesus Christ it's more
adult version of Seymour butts bro do
you believe that one too
uh uh I mean look obviously if someone
catches it they're gonna be like dude
don't do that yeah but like for the
guided it's not funny enough outraged
it's just not funny enough to do
I agree with that but but but that's not
what he asked at all so it's it's was he
out of line didn't want to use his name
right he says no he's not out of line
yeah I guess it's like when I gotta fly
off the handle and then get him in
trouble with his boss
dude that's out no tattletail [__] you
know what that is that is nutrageous
narc he's a narc this is not right it is
a nutrageous it is a nut rage okay okay
he's a narc dude that's [__] yeah I
don't like narcs man I don't like narcs
and this is a nut rage
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I mean dude you so here's the
answer
obviously it was stupid to do that yeah
because you should have known like maybe
somebody would be like man don't do that
yeah but the fact that they did that
yeah is Extreme and idiotic and it puts
any of the amount that you were in the
wrong like they just basically put you
in the right by being even worse than
you yeah okay that's true dude yeah but
every action has a reaction and I live
by that oops the most empty uh things
you know that you say I just think that
life is a highway we've got smiley face
doilies wow go to the next one before he
gets into it
we are selling a neon yellow smiley face
doily
the craft work
that goes into this
is absolutely top
tier craft work you have a this is and I
would say
four inches across and both every way
because it's a circle so the diameter is
four inches
the uh what do you call it what's the
what's the other one
circumference is I would say 12 inches
you get this right here
twelve dollars uh we will be throwing in
orange we will be throwing in
turquoise we will be throwing in some
Ray-Bans all right next well I got lost
hey what's up man Chris it's your boy
Andrew from Portland Oregon
oh dude you started over at a mini
stroke
hey what's up man Chris it's your boy
Amber from Portland Oregon and uh just
want to congratulate y'all for doing
such an amazing job with lifeline
Blue Point crushing it
um
schnitzel Hall boy that was amazing
thank you
uh Matt
I'm still sexy
my question today is we just got back
from a wedding shower uh minding my
fiance's wedding shower about a week ago
we're giving this gift
Yeah Boy what is it um I don't know if
you're familiar with that doohickey
that's a volcano hybrid and that's the
creme de La Creme smoking devices not me
um uh probably like a six seven hundred
dollars whoa which is the root of our
question sell it what do we do with it
it made me my fiance very uncomfortable
because of the price point
um we could use that money for weddings
wedding Moon
honeymoon it's okay wedding honeymoon
literally anything else I have no idea
um this guy's great yeah what do we do
send it back ask for a receipt I'm using
it probably gonna continue to use it I
don't know okay you can't sell it to do
it's crazy will we live in love you oh
what a great guy how much is that guy
the best kisser honestly honestly no
he's the best best best break dancer no
but that's obvious it does it with the
hat but I'm saying the dark thing is the
Dark Horse thing is he's such a good
kisser he just relaxes into it you know
what I mean like he kisses
no one does that no one does that okay I
mean he rather access into it he just he
like melts into the lady and just uh
she's like oh my God is that good yeah
it is he's just it is actually it looks
silly with no one else it looks silly
with no one else like with no one else
and I'm just uh but if I have another
person there like my wife goes crazy
when I do that okay my wife is she just
goes crazy okay
that's cool anyway uh
sell it sell it because what already
used it though you know so but then it's
still worth three four hundred dollars
you know it's like sell it buy it get
the amount no the Hat I know what you
did last time part of his vibe that is
from the I Know What You Did Last Summer
Collection here's the thing you season
judge people based on your standard of
what you think of what they're
presenting the real way to judge them is
by the standard of the vibe that they
either realize or do not realize that
they are putting out there that guy's
Vibe is absolutely correct with the hat
okay
consider all I'm asking you to do
is consider the vibe
okay here the Columbia fleece on yeah it
was a zip up it looked good he had the
glasses like the wire rim glasses yeah
you know so he had that skin color
that's like really really good yeah it's
good Premier skin color this is like a
[__] awesome he's like don't he's
like a mix of everything you know what I
mean he's like the perfect specimen and
this the hat for a little flavor at the
end it's good dude he did have a lot of
flavor he did he was doing all the moves
I think you should sell it
yeah we think you should sell it because
that's not a thing that a true adult
who's about to get married should need
or even want the person who got it for
you was an interesting person to say the
very least but yeah but
um they shouldn't it's not an
appropriate wedding shower gift just who
gets you a vape station when you're
[__] getting married 700 Vape station
yeah nuts it looks like a [__] City
not for an adult it's just frankly it's
just not for an adult you know yeah I
know it get honestly sell it and buy a
sybian for your wife you think that like
he it's not for an adult
yeah
a serious adult Endeavor I would not
send someone off with that yeah he's
like I don't know what to do and then
it's in a video his wife's like yeah
dude like
I have no idea it seems like the
weirdest gift that being said if you and
your wife love to smoke weed and
obviously it's not like out of hand and
you're not like having kids and being
baked all the time uh then great then
it's probably gonna save you money at
some to some degree in the in the future
but like assuming not that because
that's more like yeah God how much does
that guy get married at a young age oh
that I mean that is that that's true
yeah how about uh do you know what a
sybian is I do know what it's hold on I
just want you to know what I said when I
said that is true what I meant was
I don't know if you knew this by the way
I said it but I was trying to convey
this that is the only true thing you
said so like now that is true about how
the rest of the stuff you said is not
true no I say a lot of true stuff you do
but I in this case I was saying now that
and not everything else you said is true
would you ever order a sybian online
what
not for your butt I don't have a vagina
I know for guests
well no because nobody wants to use the
same Sybian you know uh well that was a
great meal
um so I don't know what everyone's doing
I know so you have to leave but uh I
have a sibian if you guys want to take
turns I actually have two so it's all
just guys there's like I don't know no
dude wait they come with penises on them
yeah man dude I thought they were just
like big vibrators that you know bro you
just get I thought the whole thing was
like no they have dildos and stuff on
them you can get attachments I honestly
didn't know that just sit on them okay
I've never used one but there's so many
oh my mind is blown right now there's so
many come on bro my mind's obviously
different colors different colors okay
but oh man they're three they're uh this
is 1300 this is like a full like when
you were renting a camera to make a
movie it's like all the different
packages on this on offer that's what
this is so a sibian as well
the egg dude whoa the G egg dude that
makes me feel like you're gonna that's
like [__] yourself it's like a doorknob
inside you so a sybian for those of you
that don't know you [__] square
losers is uh just basically uh something
you sit on and you can insert it inside
you and then they're all such tiny dicks
uh those ones yeah mine are yeah oh yeah
those are all so no no they have other
they're bigger ones no no no but even
those are tiny to me
you know oh wow that's the finger that
was the last one on their list like
should we make it or not if somebody was
like just do it we're making so much
money off the joke we're making all
these other ones you know they made so
much money oh the two the two what oh
for see you know our our mom and dad
watch this podcast every episode did you
know that of course and they say we talk
about our penis too much really that's
what they said to me no they didn't come
to you together and say look no but they
did they said you talk about your penis
too much on the podcast and and my mom's
like yeah your dad said it that's it
first yeah wow what a traitor uh-huh I
know dude
so anyway sorry but we're not we're
talking about a sybian yeah I mean I
wasn't talking at all about my penis I
know neither was I but those are you
actually I can tell you did talk about
your penis a little bit today the arrow
like we know uh it goes on most we know
ever okay oh it's only six inches oh
that's that's that's that's hilarious
it's only six inches the most we know
imaginable
[Laughter]
yeah all right cool so
all right let's go to the next one next
one trade it for a Sybian
wow who's buying a couple hold on okay
card hold on one second now let me save
it all right so okay check out later all
right cool so anyway what's up Matt and
Chris you guys literally keep me going
live dude anyway
that's the thing okay my mom has been
dating her boyfriend for like seven or
eight years literally awesome guy okay
gets along with everyone in our family
love him spent holidays birthdays with
him
Etc I have three brothers too so and we
all live within like 20 minutes of each
other so we see each other a lot hung
out with him a lot my mom breaks up with
him recently just no hard feelings
wasn't working for her anymore
he's taking it really hard I don't know
I feel sad as [__] for him yeah my mom
texts me and is like hey do you feel the
want or the need to say goodbye to this
person and I'm like don't phrase it like
a funeral what also I don't know
what I would say do you do that in
person do you text or is that supremely
douchey
do you just kind of like Let It Go in
separate ways and that's
unfortunately do what do you want to
hear from this person's family
help me
just text him in caps LOL
that's tough dude it is tough but it's
her and I don't know I guess I don't
know your relationship you guys just
said you had such a good you know good
she said that was really good uh I think
that you
should oh God yeah I don't know I mean I
I I don't think you want to make a whole
production out of saying goodbye because
you're right it's not a funeral it's
also like
um I mean if the here's my my normal
thought if someone was like my parent my
mom has been with with this guy who I
love for the last seven eight years but
the no hard feelings they're breaking up
yeah I wouldn't assume that the person
talking to me is gonna not he's gonna
cut off all communication with that guy
like they're close now that's true she's
an adult this guy's an adult too like I
wouldn't assume there's no good buys at
all yeah the mom's being a little bit
weird about it if it's all if everybody
if it's no hard feelings all around and
obviously the guy's butt hurt but like
that doesn't mean you cut off
communication with all parties it's like
that's eight years of your life that you
bonded with more than just one person
the person like your mom doesn't get to
say you can't talk to that person
anymore like this is two other adults
now with their own feelings about one
other I agree yeah so first of all the
premise that your mom is putting it to
you is just is false it's like a false
premise yeah yeah be like Mama what are
you talking about if you text me then
that's I'm gonna write back if he
doesn't yeah I won't like what the [__]
you know or maybe I'll text him if
something funny happens like whatever
everybody eight years yeah yeah so I
think turn the tables on your mom first
of all for making you feel like you have
to do this thing that you obviously are
awkward to do at the very least
don't do it don't do it and don't
presume that that's how adults should
act anyway like if you like this guy
keep him in your life don't or at least
don't cut him out of your life no just
don't cut him out of your life for no
reason that's all I'm saying I'm not
saying like keep him involved go get ice
cream with them every week but like you
don't have to excise him and let him
know that it's just like that's yeah
it's a weird that's a weird request 100
I agree that being said if you're gonna
do it
I don't even know like if you if you're
bent on doing it I don't even know what
to say what what should she say uh uh
LOL
just LOL you don't that's so [__]
horrible to just be like yo it was nice
to know you I agree dude it's not just
weird it makes things weird it's gonna
make him reach back out to her yep you
know yeah it's gonna make everything
worse for everybody actually let me just
send him a sybian and call him a dick
call it a day yeah send them to Sybian
you send to everybody
in your life you don't want the finger
yeah don't want the bell end uh all
right and then the attachment
dude that sucks for that last guess
though I feel bad yeah yeah it's a
terrible situation yeah okay well Karma
Chris hi Matt massive fan of the show
massive fan and congratulations I've
been listening for years now uh my
question it was about flying okay
that guy is my favorite person in the
history of humanity why okay he's
definitely somebody else hey Ma what's
up what's going on with my brother
tonight he's got the gauges yeah he's
definitely gonna tattoo his eyeballs one
day get this though he's in he's in a
car in the mountains somewhere pulled
over on the side of the road he's moving
he's in the mountains right now all
right
going up uh I'm 30 years old even though
I look about 14 and I'm mad at my mum
for taking away my Xbox console and I've
got a huge huge fear of flying
uh I've just been to Italy for a week
with my partner
um and on both flights there I've been
constantly stressing out everything is
so unnatural to me all the different
bumps and movements and and sounds I'm
just it's like I'm trying to get out of
my skin almost I'm grabbing onto her for
dear life I'm grabbing onto like the the
net in front of me on the seat in front
of me as if that's going to do something
um and you know everyone around me so
chill and I'm just sort of almost
like my brain's trying to convince me
something bad's gonna happen the the
days leading up to Flying I'm I'm a
different person I'm super duper
stressed
um and yeah just need some advice on how
to deal with it do I just need to do it
more uh will you were you stressed yeah
and nervous before flying when you were
younger uh or or do you still get
anxious now
um I just I do need to stress though how
unbearable it is at times because I mean
like even on on the plane home we were
coming in to land and I think there was
another plane on the runway and we got
almost to the ground and he and the
pilot just took off again right well
that's kind of and everyone around me
super chill they're reading the paper
they're just talking and I'm just
clinging onto her for dear life and
going okay well I'll give half my half
my savings to my mom half my savings to
my sister and I'm just gonna die now
okay bye
um yeah so any any help would be
appreciated so yeah any any help making
it longer just once
back ten back ten I mean dude it's yeah
I used to be really scared of flying I
wouldn't go places and then I started I
started regretting it but I just think
that exposure therapy is good also dude
just take an Ativan or you have
something against like
you know I mean that that kind of
anxiety isn't something you're supposed
to feel yes so take an Ativan in those
moments I don't suggest you know relying
on drugs but I think that you know
unless you got a weird aversion towards
we all know my story so yeah drugs are
good you only take one don't take some
somebody's secret drug in front of you
don't take the whole bottle yeah yeah
and definitely don't accept drugs from
the person in front of you even no
matter how nice they are especially if
you've already taken a certain drug and
no matter how well they mean yeah it
doesn't really you wake up you look up
touching someone
um you wake up at a 7-Eleven in Los
Angeles and don't know how you got there
you did that basically no I knew I got
there oh God I was like
who took me here who's outside with me
oh my who oh my oh my okay well so
um yeah it sucks but it you know what
prompts you for doing it but I I
understand dude flying is unnatural it's
like you shouldn't be that high in the
air where humans not birds and uh
uh but yeah I would just say get a
prescription man that [__] really helps
but if you want a non I fully agree yeah
medication as always the number one yeah
uh I got another thing to say but uh
what I when I used to I used to freak
out a whole lot more about just not as
bad as him because you were like yeah
crazy right super scared like a great
big baby and stuff and it changed but
yeah but I I also didn't like it like I
would get uncomfortable during takeoff
and Landing the thing that would
actually calm me down the most was
something you said me which would no you
didn't I've said my favorite guy in the
history of humanity oh him yeah uh
you look at the other people and it's
clear but the the behavior of all of
them yeah that this is normal yeah if
you look around and everyone as he says
is just reading the paper counting it up
thinking about you know sleeping you're
not in trouble except for the fact that
when it is when people are like what the
[__] then you are gonna start feeling
weird here's what I think that's never
happened well sometimes oh okay I've
never been on a plane where people are
actually scared except me and then I
look around and I'm like oh nobody else
is scared all right so I don't have to
be scared they obviously know something
about I don't know I have something
great to do what I have something great
to do I think oh you should
uh this is this is the best thing that
has helped me it's so egotistical to
think that your flight is gonna go down
because you're on it there's so many
other people on there you don't think
that about their flight you think that
about your flight even though they're on
it too it's egotistical you don't matter
that much so quit well
I actually think that applies in a lot
of instances but not this one but I get
what you're saying you can take the
dollars you can put them both you can
match them look at that oh dude green
and turquoise let me see look at that
look at that yeah it is very cool right
okay two two different ones it's not a
feature though you know you just figured
that out look what else you can do with
these look you can put them in your
pockets
um okay all right cool more more more
having sex oh Lifeline crew this is Eric
from Salt Lake City again I'll be there
I just wanted to thank Matt first of all
for his response to my previous
submission and then congratulations to
Chris on his boy his baby boy thanks
dude uh I just wanted to get their
advice on so many likes how would you
Wrangle and Tangle somebody into
watching an horror film or a horror show
um because so many people nowadays like
to watch drama our reality [__]
[__] and just kind of skip over you
know movies like skin marink what would
you introduce a person to first to get
them into that kind of horror film or
show like what what horror film or show
would you introduce a person to so well
first first that's an interesting it is
a good question but first of all you sit
them down look at them straight in the
eye and say you are wasting your life oh
you are wasting your life on stupid ass
stupid [__] reality TV now here's screen
it's time and it's time to open your
mind yep now here's [__] you know
another bad one I can't think of it uh
uh The Terrorizer what's it called
Anthony uh terrifier terrifier yes
Anthony who works on the show here he
loves the terrifier movie series the
sequel terrifier 2 just recently came
out and the interesting thing about that
is it's horrible it's absolutely 100
Terrible yeah the guys just like this
ha ha ha ha
I mean that would be good if that was
the guy like that viewer oh if it was no
makeup and it was just me doing that
yeah it would be amazing holy [__] bro
that would be so scary we gotta make
that movie yeah okay so what
I said yeah okay okay I just want you to
agree with that man
um I could if I wanted to okay fine
um so wait uh this is what is this a
what is the thing you get how do you get
them to do it okay and what is the thing
you show them if they agree to do well
this is timely for me okay because last
night oh wow yeah I watched I like I
like Thrillers I like Horrors I like you
know yes right yeah
and I know you know this movie and I
know I think you like this movie I
watched the I watched audition I love
auditions okay yeah so that movie is
extremely boring right I mean I don't
think so no I like it
but it's boring well what do you mean
people really argue it's not what do you
but then what do you mean by very slow
it's very oh it's slow to reveal what
it's really about you can watch it for
an hour and not know it's a horror movie
yeah I don't know about it yes you can
you can for a full hour you can watch it
and it's a romantic movie
oh I know it okay okay
um okay yeah but but I watched it and I
I I I I I I I couldn't stay awake but I
liked the movie but man the two people I
was with were like this is [__] come
on really yeah you're uh yeah it's a
classic
it's like top 10
uh what do you call it horror movies
especially in Japan oh yeah it was a
huge hit in Japan yeah Takashi Mike or
whatever the [__] the guy is right the
director and um
he uh I think it's his best movie they
they you do I think yeah you've seen
them all that get you the Killer and all
I mean he makes like three movies a year
sometimes so there's so much I've seen
the big ones like Ichi and is he too
good each of the Killer is good uh
what's the recent one he did the reason
he actually made a Samurai movie 13
um Warriors assassins yeah I didn't know
he did that yeah he did that he does all
different kinds of [__] too uh the the
happy mura clummies there's some there's
some like he makes the weird every genre
every weird he's like Kubrick kind of
sat there always actually nothing like
Kubrick but that's just like a Kubrick
guy he's nothing even a little bit like
Kubrick but that's cool yeah so we're
talking because it's Japanese but it's
just like
um
the how what would you show them though
I don't know but but I wanted to talk
about addition oh okay then keep going
what do you think about that movie I
like it I love it I think it's why do
you love it so much well I like it
starts out it's about a guy who is a
Widow Widow widower what do you call it
he's a widower yeah and his wife his
wife died seven years ago and the his
son is finally like hey why don't you
you got you gotta find someone so he uh
pairs up with this other guy who
produces movies and this guy they hold
an audition for this movie that they are
going to make but the guy the other guy
suggests
um hey
uh whoever the runner-up is why don't
you try to take her out maybe you pick
somebody that you're from the audition
process that you think you could be with
it's basically like a good guy version
of the typical casting count yeah
totally right he's like oh okay you know
that's such a thing yeah I mean it's bad
because what's the premise the premise
the whole movie not the spoiler alert is
about a long play of his punishment for
being like that right yes okay right
um and so the the
um
so I so so I watched it last night and
an hour and I fell asleep I couldn't do
I'm gonna finish it tonight but I think
I've seen it before I've seen it before
yeah okay I just love generally I love
Japanese oh I did the best horror movies
except for no the best horror movies are
the the Dutch or Norwegian or whatever
the [__] is up there with all the blonde
hair and all that no yeah because the
Japanese the way that they are about
death and the dead is way different than
they are than we are in the west about
yeah death and dying I know like the way
they have ghosts they're not like
necessarily these scary stories okay you
know what you're doing doing is you keep
you keep stomping on what I'm saying you
know what I'm talking about and it's
making me angry very angry we're gonna
have a horror movie on our hands if you
keep doing it wow that's a good thing to
say if you're gonna get into a fight wow
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
have a horror movie on our hands if you
keep going yeah yeah that's good yeah
it's not a good thing just in a vacuum
though I just did it okay okay so say I
did good not that is you did good so
okay go ahead
uh I completely forget what I was saying
but if I was gonna show someone a horror
movie uh
like if I if I was trying to get them to
understand why this that the genre is
great I probably wouldn't pick something
like audition no you couldn't or
something classic like The Shining
anything that's remotely obscure yeah
you kind of want to avoid you can
eventually get into that oops right
because you're still stomping on what
I'm doing right so we're gonna stop
doing a conversation but yeah
uh but I'd avoid it like the plague but
I don't know that's a good question like
to hook to hook somebody on the horror
genre
I would say maybe The Exorcist but
that's a little old now you might get
someone being like this is boring
because just because it's old I know
what to do the ring is a good one the
original one no the American American
one okay the original one is not as
scary as the American one and I'm the
only guy who says I don't think yeah the
original one's not that scary I I mean
okay but I don't think the American
remake is scarier the American ring is
[__] scary
I don't know if I agree with that
actually yeah it's pretty good yeah
um and and honestly for an American
movie I think that that's the movie
you know that's old now though yeah I
know but it's still you it's still
watchable it's not like the 80s bro no
it's 2000 something yeah no yeah yeah it
was when did the ring come out like
probably before that yeah 2002. yeah it
done too yeah I was right I was very
close very close
um
yeah
yeah I don't know
but I don't think I don't think I've
showed them the ring though but why not
um
I mean I guess just trying to get them
to like it but if they like it but if
they don't like movies or if they don't
like they watch reality TV
you know I mean you gotta get them on
something more like like wild or
something you know oh like scream like
terrifier
nobody would ever watch another horror
movie if the way you tried to convince
them to watch horror movies and the
reason to like them is to show them
terrifier yeah sorry Anthony
um you guys haven't seen it
I I did I tried to see it I tried to
watch it too but it's right like halfway
he's right that I didn't finish it yeah
you haven't watched the second one
though that is true I would though for
you I would to honor how much I disagree
with you I would watch the whole second
one
in fact I'm gonna do that I don't know
man I love horror movies
you know what though that's the thing
you're saying Dad hates them it's like
people if they don't if you're trying to
get someone an adult to like horror
movies it's not gonna work they already
don't like them yeah that's true horror
is not something you get people that are
wishy-washy on either I've always said
this about horror movies they
are often they they as a genre they
carry the most promises they always they
they're capable of being the best movies
like some of my very favorite movies are
horror movies but so often they are
actually the very very worst yeah so
many it's like r b music so much of that
genre yeah is is absolute trash yeah
like the [__] Anthony lives
you know some of it it's a very small
amount but still they exist have you
guys seen Cabin in the Woods yeah that's
a great movie but that's not a horrible
it's not a great movie but it's okay
it's not a horror movie yeah it's not
horrible it kind of you know it kind of
is it kind of is uh yeah it's funny if
it's funny like that it's not a horror
movie and now we're making rules I love
that we're making we just saw that movie
recently okay it's just so watchable
dude
okay okay no no no that's the thing a
movie being watchable is the thing okay
all right
all right all right do another one yeah
let's go
here we go nice what's up man Chris
I recently quit eating
and it's going pretty well I've noticed
a ton of benefits in my energy levels
and
I have way more control over what I'm
eating and my cravings and stuff like
that
um so breaking that addiction was really
good for me overall my question is about
the reactions you get from other people
when you make certain changes in your
life
uh for example
a lot of people have sort of had a major
reaction
to me quitting saying that you know oh
it's not healthy or you need to have
things in moderation you should deprive
yourself
and while I think that might apply in
certain cases I think for me
it doesn't
um I had to do it cold turkey just
because I don't have that self-control
and even after telling them this I still
have to deal with it at every meal you
know declining a dessert you kind of get
like the eye rolls or people you know
huffing and puffing about it and it's
just discouraging because like I wanted
to try something like fasting you know
like 48 hour fast
something along those lines and I know
that as soon as people find out I'm
gonna do it
it's just going to be the same thing all
over again and if either of you have
ever fasted or tried to cut out anything
like that you know that
you just want to distract yourself you
don't want to have people constantly
bring it up you know if I was trying to
quit
cocaine or something and people were
always like well why don't you just have
a little bit Yeah
trigger you know it makes no sense but
when it's you'd agree
like sugar it's like
it goes right over their head so these
are people that mean well and they get
it so I know that they're not okay so
but also grow some balls though you know
what I mean but yeah but grow some balls
but trigger City but grow some balls
right
drinking at a time of my life when I
still had tons and tons of friends that
drank a lot so I that would be my
comparison
but as my brother is saying grow some
balls because all you really need to do
is just like say
push back on it if they actually come at
you for it but yeah the no is no and you
can just ignore all the [__] eye
rolls because here's the deal
they're just like oh like he's so fussy
like yeah because they're [__] lazy
[__] of course dude and they're jealous
dude and this is what you can say to
them oh yeah you know what be fussy and
that's fine but I'm gonna be but but go
ahead and laugh your way into your grave
and I'll be standing there pissing on
Your Grave wow okay well don't say any
of that but you could do that if you're
John Malkovich and then the line of fire
or in that situation it's kind of like
armchair psychologists to be like
they're just jealous of you that might
not be the case but they're like he's
fussy and I don't do fussy that's like
that's the way that's like the
underscore underlining of like all of
that kind of behavior okay then I'm
gonna piss on your grade towards people
who scoff at you for changing something
up and quote being difficult but dude
who cares these people are obviously not
hip to the thing that you're hip to and
like which is how it's expected that
people this is how people act they act
like Oh Mr fussy okay fine yeah eye
rolls looking at each other being like
Oh yeah he doesn't do it anymore
who cares I'll be laughing when I'm
peeing on Your Grave okay or you could
do that or you could do that version do
you think I get that it's frustrating
but at the end of the day the only the
reason I'm saying who cares this is the
only way to get over it and the only way
to sort of like get your hand back on
top of theirs is just to be like I don't
play that game when we don't play that
Homie don't play that Homie don't play
that I'll be laughing at that when I pee
on your grave Homie don't play that
thing yeah the only way to win this is
to is to engage in what I like to call
Homie don't play that
it's not everything in moderation you
know
people say everything in moderation not
everything in moderation murder there's
one huge thing that there shouldn't be
moderation about there should be zero
murdering um
right and sugar those two things no but
I just feel like yeah people are doing
this because they everything in
moderation is an idiotic thing to say
yep I get it but it's like come on
murder there's so many ways to poke
holes in that stupid murder I just did
it yeah but that's
obvious genocide how about that nuclear
bombs I mean the the expression implies
of the things to do but that's not what
they're saying yeah it is basically it's
implied everything in moderation but
what he's saying is cocaine is a thing
to do so that in moderation well no
because it's Gonna Make You predictable
marching powder and some moderation wow
the fact that you interrupted me just
because you wanted to say Bolivian
marching powder you know
really something it's going to be
marching down your face
most annoying eye on the history in the
history of between that and the Janus
Joplin I really killed this episode oh
God
damn it
yeah Johnny Mitchell and it is what it
is I almost blocked it out of my memory
but thanks for bringing it back Tony
Mitchell Janice Joplin who's Janice
Joplin well Janice stop is a different
singer I know but what is she sing uh
the Mercedes-Benz song
I guarantee that's the thing I'm saying
no man you can't do that because you
don't know that and there's no way to
argue with it
I guarantee she's saying that what's the
person that's arguing with you gonna say
oh yeah oh I guarantee she didn't right
so I got you on detector no that's very
stupid and you argue like all I'm saying
is that you don't need to eat sugar and
grow some balls and also that's a lot
that's live people are just gonna be
like can I have you know oh you're a
[__] boy right that's what happened oh
you oh dude you don't oh you're better
than us it's yeah it's the implication
that you're better than us or no more
than us or whatever but again I'm a bad
guy because I snort fun dip okay the
only way to
take your power back in a situation like
that is again to do a little thing I
like to call Homie don't play that okay
okay I like to call it that everybody
else can call it something else but the
thing I like to call it is Homie don't
play that okay cool well then that's
fine great um I will be in Nashville I
will be in different cities I will be in
uh Ottawa and uh Montreal uh go to
christian.com for tickets I'll be in
Philadelphia you know it's just gonna be
balls to the wall there's gonna be so
crazy man it's gonna be absolutely
insane yeah I think it is yeah yeah so
go to watch go to watch lifeline.com if
you got a question and uh Magic the
garage
uh you know or you can leave us a
message on uh the lifeline hotline like
that fella that last fella just did at
213-973-8095 and of course you could get
one on one-on-one sessions with me your
boy baby baby Matt Delia at
mattdelia.com and speaking of get the
new Lifeline merch at lifelinemerch.com
you can get the amazing purple hoodies
you can get the the sweatshirt one with
the little emblem in the corner it's
over the breast it's very very good it's
very very sexy stuff that uh if you
don't buy it you don't love us you don't
love us and honestly if you don't at
least leave a comment you don't love us
honestly yeah you don't and if you don't
subscribe you don't love us subscribe to
super good Studios or you don't love us
but the best part is is that if you do
do those things we not only do you love
us but we love you and most of you if
not probably all of you are now my best
friend and his best friend oh wow okay
okay yeah okay sure only if they like it
And subscribe though right I understand
thank you very much
[Music]